Matrix that describes the measurement outcome so let's take a look at this in a little bit more detail if we think
abstractly about about a general measurement we can describe that measurement as a channel fi the input system for the channel is
whatever system X is being measured and the output system is a system y whose classical States correspond to the
measurement outcomes which we're taking to be the integers from 0 to n minus one for some positive integer
M and because measurement outcomes are classical we require that for every input density Matrix Row for the system
X the output five row must be a diagonal density Matrix for example if we think about a
standard basis measurement of a cubit and we think about that measurement as being described by a channel we can express it as we have here on the screen
if the input density Matrix is row then we'll get the outcome zero with probability equal to bra 0o row cat Zer
and we'll get the outcome one with probability bra one row Kat one and so if we express these classical
measurement outcomes as density matrices we'll get this expression for the corresponding Channel and it turns out
that it's none other than the completely def phasing Channel and that's consistent with the idea that the completely def phasing
Channel represents an extreme form of decoherence which can mean different things but when I use that term I'm
talking about the tendency for Quantum States to become classical because the environment around whatever system we're
talking about is watching in some sense or in other words it's measuring
so measurement outcomes can be described as channels as I've just described but this is not just a possibility it's a
characterization of General measurements and what I mean by that is the following of course there are channels
that don't represent measurements because the output might not always be a diagonal density Matrix but if it is the
case that the output of a channel is always a diagonal density Matrix regardless of what input State row we choose then it is necessar possible to
express that channel in the form that's shown on the screen for some choice of a measurement meaning a collection of
positive semidefinite matrices that sum to the identity and that's nice for multiple reasons including the fact that it
basically tells us that our definition of measurements as collections of matrices isn't missing
anything another way of saying that is that this way of thinking about measurements as channels is operational
or axiomatic perhaps in the sense that it captures what a measurement should be which is a physical process that
transforms Quantum information into classical information and it turns out that it's completely equivalent to our first
description of measurements which is purely algebraic I won't go through the proof of the equivalence in this video but it
isn't difficult and if you're interested you can find the proof in the written material for the lesson which is linked in the video
description we've discussed what happens when a general measurement is performed on a system in a given state
at least for the case of destructive measurements next we'll talk about partial measurements meaning that just
one part of a compound system is measured to be precise let's suppose that we have a pair of systems XZ that
together are in a state described by a density Matrix row and a measurement described by a collection of positive semi-definite matrices that sum to the
identity is performed on the system X alone naturally this results in in a
measurement outcome and because we're talking about destructive measurements we can imagine that the process of measurement destroys the system
X but we still have the system Z to worry about and we need to understand how the measurement of X affects the
state of Z first let's talk about the outcome
probabilities because we're talking about a measurement of the system X alone the probabilities for different
outcomes to appear can only depend on the state of X in isolation which is to say that they can only depend on the
reduced state of X in particular the probability for a given outcome a to appear is given by
the same formula from before which is the trace of PA times the reduced state of X which we denote by Row
subx the state row subx is obtained from row by tracing out Z so we can make that
substitution and although it might not be immediately obvious the question we get can alternatively be written as is
shown on the screen it's the trace of PA tensored with the identity Matrix on the system Z *
row now that's an equality that's definitely worth taking some time to verify it's intuitive we're not doing
anything at all to Z so it makes sense that the identity on Z should show up like this but it can also be verified
algebraically and I will leave that to you along with the suggestion to First consider the case that row is is a tensor product of two matrices and then
use linearity to conclude that it must work for all row and I'll also say that it does not depend on the fact that PA
is positive semi-definite or that row is a density Matrix this is an equality that would work for any choice of
matrices in place of PA and row as long as they have the right dimensions for the expression to make
sense and now let's see how the state of Z is affected by the measurement and the natural approach in
my view is to think about the measurement as a channel here's the channel that we associate with our measurement and we're
thinking about this as a channel from the system X to a new system y whose classical States correspond to the measurement outcomes so in this formula
Sigma represents a state of the system X alone if we apply this channel to the
system X while the pair XZ is in the state row then we'll obtain the density Matrix that we have right here again
take as much time as you need to verify this and again my suggestion is to First consider the case that row is a tensor
product of two matrices and then use linearity now we saw this type of state
where the first system is classical and the second system is quantum as an example in the density Matrix
lesson each a occurs with some probability and that's the trace of the second tensor Factor so you can think
about these second tensor factors as being density matrices multiplied by probabilities so to obtain the state of
Z conditioned on obtaining a particular measurement outcome a we simply divide out the probability or in other words we
normalize the second tensor Factor by dividing it by its own Trace so in summary if we perform a
measurement on X while the pair XZ is in the state row this is what happens first each outcome a appears
with probability equal to the trace of PA tensored with the identity time row and second conditioned on obtaining